würdest du dich trauen gegen einen der
bekanntesten köche aus deutschland in
einer challenge anzutreten die frage hat
mit ozawa gusto gestellt ich habe sie
mit ja beantwortet ihr seht ihr oben
schon werbung eingeblendet ich wurde von
gustavo gusto zu einem pizza battle
eingeladen gegen roland trettl der first
date fernseh sternekoch roland trettl
und mein erster gedanke war wie sowie in
aller welt soll das funktioniert kurz
zum hintergrund der challenge wir gehen
in einen eigens kreierten laden haben
dort eine bestimmte zeit um uns zu
packen was uns in dem moment gerade
einfällt daraus kreieren wir dann eine
pizza ebenfalls innerhalb von zehn
minuten dann packen wir die und am ende
kommt ein jura der entscheidet welche
pizza besser ist roland trettl greift
auf jahrelange kulinarische erfahrung
und ausbildung als koch zurück und ich
mache seit eineinhalb jahren mit videos
es war so ein bisschen david gegen
goliath aber gesagt getan ab in diesem
kühlraum voller lebensmittel du merkst
nur die zeit läuft dort heimisch gegen
roland trettl losgeht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim wetter den
bettel
die spannung steigt und es mag sein dass
in der luft der junge kerl behauptet
dass er die beste pizza oder pasta pizza
als ich hinkam
mozzarella brauche ich hab ich mir das
basilikum brauche ich tatsächlich
den ganzen bus nehme ich mir auch mal so
mit uns nicht in den mozzarella rein
[Musik]
panne sei noch mehr gott der sich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr nach
paris aus
wird schon funktionieren käse käse
[Musik]
ich brauchte eigentlich gekochten fisch
also ich bin jetzt schon ins schwitzen
gekommen
minute die hat mich jetzt schon fertig
gemacht das war gar nicht so leicht oder
also man steht da drin und plötzlich ist
so viel da und weiß gar nicht was nehmen
soll ich habe allerdings die sache
bekommen ich wollte den fans aber schon
sehr oder ich habe sie auch bekommen was
ich wollte aber weil ich auch nicht
wusste was ich wollte es ist ja schon so
ist's her dass hand als die bisher sehr
neutral von den farmen ja ich bin doch
sehr ins mediterrane ich weiß nicht wie
hier zu sicher und octopus kombiniere
musst du alles verwenden er klar er
danke das tut sie liegen noch vor gibt
ja es ist die regel nein aber meine
sachen sind gut zusammen gekommen ich
bin erleichtert bist du koch nein bin
ich nicht aber ich habe letztens einmal
in die sterne davor reingeschnuppert
willst ja also ich glaub ich glaube ich
habe da auch wir haben müssen gearbeitet
sagen also ich habe noch ein bisschen
aber auch mal so lange aber aus
leidenschaft aus leidenschaft ab und
weiß was das ist gar nicht ein nachteil
weil ich habe schon viele amateur kirche
kennengelernt auch in verschiedenen
formaten ja die besser waren als der
koch also profitaucher profi tochter
wirklich schon so sein
vorgefertigtes schema hat was das kochen
angelangt und dann kommen mögen wie du
und sagen schon völlig frei aus hälfte
raus und aber ich werde es beobachten ja
ich werde auch beim giro waffen da ist
es wirklich eine wahnsinnige feature und
octopus wie kriegst du das unter einen
deckel ich möchte jetzt auch nicht mehr
coachen man auch weiß jetzt auch nicht
durch sollte ich also ich muss jetzt
wirklich machen ich muss auch mal die
weiß bereit zehn minuten zehn minuten
aber zeit wir uns in fünf sekunden 5 4 3
hernandez hatte wurde hier ist jetzt
alles so läuft ja sicher doch da habe
ich die ganze zeit schon gehabt dass mir
die fleisch verbrennen auch nicht allzu
viele aber die fahrt von gut hitze was
machst du da drüben ja ich bin mir jetzt
noch nicht so sicher ob ich jetzt was
ich am park oder was ich gesagt hab
überlegt ist die jetzt gerade
so entspannt du hast die leichtigkeit
und ich habe die erfahrung ja aber
wirklich ich glaube mich hier schneiden
sehen würdest wenn ich konzentriert dass
wir den kopf schütteln ich brauche ganz
viel basilikum maßnahmen keine mario
sondern ein festival zu machen die
leichtigkeit ist jetzt schon gut bissel
druck aufzubauen und
sie sind wir sind einige minuten sind
wir schon drin ok so schön ab 10 uhr ein
bisschen schnell machen wo war die zeit
vergeht trotzdem das bereite ich auch
schon mal vorab schon mal mein
mozzarella
du sprichst aber ich liebe es zu
sprechen du nicht so gerne ich bin echt
mal koßler weiß sigrid deshalb bin ich
herr koch geworden um das ich nicht wir
reden muss ja ja also werde ich ja noch
dazu sonst wäre ich ja keiner geworden
jetzt muss ich meinen käsereien der kein
paar mehr sein ist weil es ihnen einfach
nicht gar seit sieben minuten 30 wie
bist du in der zeit ich lass mir ich
kann es noch nicht so aufgeregt neben so
einem sterne küchen praxis kann ich
natürlich verstehen also ich bin
gespannt wie oktopus und saskia hin
kommt ja aber die grundidee war ich habe
das gesehen und ich habe ja doch schon
eine zeit lang in spanien gelebt und da
gibt es ja diese sogar asada auf
mallorca oder tourist der spanische
paprika wurst wie hier dann auch wieder
ganz gerne mit mehr als richten
kombiniert wird damit eine reihe
auslassen schon eine alte battle jahr
aber die energie muss trotzdem eine gute
bleibt ja auch gut also wenn ein
bisschen knoblauch brand dann habe ich
gar nicht mit eingepackt
sechs nur noch es wird es gab jetzt kann
es überhaupt den weg nehmen das wäre
wissen so christa so nett ich haue ich
glaube dass sogar an mamma mia und
service hier jetzt braucht man stabmixer
wer ist schon seine pizza belegen da
drüben dass wir unglaublich aber der ist
ja die besten tipps am ende dazu wurde
ja genau meine passion games am ende
drauf den thunfisch gebe es auch am ende
drauf so hatte ich es mir gemütlich
gemacht und platz machen für meine pizza
biolitec auch über pizza purer
wohlgemerkt das ist ja das schöne an der
ganzen sache jeder kann draufpackt
wasser will in kabul von ihr genommen
das ist okay schütte ich alles nicht
mehr nur die csu gibt stichworte ich
wollte nämlich auch zeigt immer ein fest
immer lägen ja eine wand hier rein ja
die wir hier ja man darf sich nicht zu
schade sein von den profis zu lernen
sehr gut jahre stellung ja pizza ist für
jetzt fertig belegt aber ich habe noch
drei minuten 30 für meine weiteren
vorbereitung ok testo darf gern ein
bisschen grüner sein tillikum ihn ein
lehrer muss ich ja auch junge ist der
gute pizza bei mir das kann das sagen
also sie sieht wunderbar aus weil ich
meine am ende des tages mal ich mir
keine zu großen börsen bewegen sich aus
ist ja was völlig unterschiedlich ist
was wir hier gerade machen oder es kam
der service auf den jauch ja darauf an
ja ob er mutig ist immer wenn wir jetzt
gleich octopus und sicher sieht und sagt
mager nicht aber nicht
ich brauche wenig geld weil ich mag
dieses paket richtig sauer irgendwas
verkehrt zu haben wirkt erst haben wir
von der arbeitsweise zitrone in pässe
wachsoldaten kunden das war probiert
wenn sie gleich verwertbar wenn sie
länger stehen ist
schwierig weil es hier doch trauen wird
ich will noch meine stärke zufrieden und
ich mache geschmacklich super ich hab
mal
eine pizza eis gelegt meine ist nackt
ich glaube aber die magie bei mir
passiert nach dem auspacken deshalb
würde ich sagen das ist ziemlich ernst
genau mit dieser peter kurer oder ja du
hast sie einfach purer gelassen das ura
klar sie kommen hoffentlich gut
aufgerufen so frei mit den teilnehmern
mit dem guten stücken genau gleichzeitig
war er kann sie jetzt ist eigentlich wie
mehr meine art als dass ich bin ja
eigentlich das ist ja ich bin bis heute
nicht so was heißt heute hat die
schweren geschütze auf ich bin gespannt
wie sie schmecken will also ich möchte
sie unbedingt probieren wirklich gehe
ich heute ja gewissen runter hoch ich
finde es aber schön wir helfen uns noch
zur soll kochen sein wechsel ja aber
doch ein gemeinsames das kann man gut
gemacht gleich eine minute eine minute
an der zeit zum finalisieren ich glaube
da wird er mein problem als ein bisschen
aufgeräumt habe ich auch nur keramischen
danke herr trettel pizza zehn minuten
gebacken magazine immer noch richtig pur
aus und schmeckt wahrscheinlich so auch
schon sehr sehr gut problem du kannst
dich entspannen und ich muss jetzt
richtig schwitzen haben wir noch eine ab
jetzt auch noch das ist nicht viel zeit
ich habe was ich mache ich habe ja
knoblauchbutter gemacht arbeiten weil
daran also was denke ich da ist ja doch
immer so ein bisschen in alter stärke er
wird mit einer geilen knoblauchbutter
einfach nochmal facebook
wird schon ging alles schnell ja also
jetzt hat sie sich doch etwas verändert
bisschen farbe hat meine pizza bekommt
also der bestrichenen waren er ist der
glanz da das glänzt richtig aber das
bringt ja alles nichts wenn wir uns hier
loben muss dann letztendlich doch nicht
was hoffentlich schmecken bestimmt
schmecken beide aber einer wird gewinnen
juror bitte einmal kommt william der ton
ist ja und wer von euch beiden hobby pc
russ hat jetzt welche von diesen pizzas
verbraucht das ist deine aufgabe das
herauszufinden also du kannst ja mal
gucken was würde zudem passen also in
erster linie muss durchaus finden sich
rechte ist ganz genau wissen kann es her
da sieht man direkt der geruchstest
interessant
[Musik]
bemerkenswert aber muss sagen das ist ja
schon alles sehr ansprechend aus
dieses pesto das vermählt sich damit die
käser diese beschlüsse ist also ganz
exklusiv vornehme das hier so nicht aber
jetzt ist die frage von wem ist
das ist jetzt gar nicht so leicht ist
also ich würde sagen diese pizza wäre
für mich der gewinner
ich weiß wo ich gratuliere dankeschön
jetzt freue ich mich zudem dank erstmal
also fühlen sich das nicht unfassbar
lecker ich möchte sie unbedingt
probieren probieren wir einfach
gegenseitig
durch sein geschäft hat sehr sehr viel
spaß gemacht ich weiß nicht was
mit mir los geht's das problem der
antwort ja gar nicht gegessen mit dem öl
bestrichen hätte er wahrscheinlich die
nötige extrapunkte gegeben
dieses unfassbar gut bis sehr gut
gemeint wartet der tintenfisch
entwickelt ein bisschen bisschen berufen
max unglaublich gut das wird schwerer
als ich eine schwere entscheidung was
für ein video vielen dank an euch beide
großen spaß macht ja wir essen ist die
beiden letzten plätzen auf und max auch
studien drittel betteln dann zeig was du
drauf hast in dem du eine pizza belegt
fotografierst auf instagram stellst und
mit dem hashtag vettel den titel text
und im idealfall bist du einer von denen
der preis bis zu 20.000 euro gewinnen
kann ich drücke die daumen es ist jetzt
schon eine weile her dass wir das ganze
gemacht haben und ich kann es immer noch
nicht so richtig glauben dass ich
wirklich gewonnen habe keine ahnung
irgendwie glück gehabt dass ich eine
gelungene kreation mir überlegt habe auf
die schnelle aber
nichtsdestotrotz das war glaube ich
keine leichte entscheidung für unseren
jura und
ich bin sehr froh dass ich gewonnen habe
ich sage aber so wie es ist roland ich
habe mich wenn ich böse dass ich
gewonnen habe du bist natürlich herzlich
willkommen auf einem kanal einen tag
versehen oder sonst was denkt ihr dass
für das sportlich genommen hast danke an
gustavo gusto dass sich das video
unterstützt haben und überhaupt erst mal
möglich gemacht haben wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder check die
beschreibung für alle infos bis dahin
und schauen